alors aujourd'hui c'est la fête de la
barque à la fête de la rigolade
alors ils ont tous préparé une entrée
drôle malheureusement je vous le dis ça
peut très vite devenir la fête de la
race rare vous avez fois le premier à
rentrer c'est jean-michel merck est avec
nous
nous ne la regardent ils verront pas ça
tombe bien c'est la [ __ ] luna partie
d'arcade c zéro race rare naquit nhk
c'est la fin d'un combat bute
jean-michel mais je vous en mi mai
pourquoi je ne me reconnais pas nommer
trois semaines quoi bouger à llorente
dark dark dark dark heures d'accord
c'est une catastrophe merci jean billon
peu nombreux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'effort
allez va limiter la dérive et l'emploi
valérie bègue et freedom park avec
street food et frites e place à des
frites est là bas record
[Musique]
c'était juste rigole t il à haute voix
mais c'est une catastrophe sur le banc
bien qu'absents sur ta tête les frais
[Applaudissements]
mais charles et d'élèves ont fait une
année magnifique
donc si vous faites une très belle
saison pourquoi je rigolais pourquoi
mais non parce que moi je suis prête à
tour dira joueurs vous aurez on dirait
un joueur de foot carlos valderrama
[Applaudissements]
voilà la triste bien cette série que
ceux ci avaient soulevé la tristesse
absolue de l'argent de la prod n'est pas
parti la toile malheureusement aussi
alors là ah oui ya les clips seeking qui
sont là mais la tristesse je les ai vus
à les y rentrer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
x
[Applaudissements]
alors voulez voter h cactées peine
bédard cas pour la meilleure entrée pour
l'instant voté pour la moins pire
on a passé tout l'après midi on jamais
les mecs mais je le savais je le savais
bref c'est le savez je connais et bien
quand même
je connais on est aux autres c'est plus
alors j'ai pas compris
en fait alors j'aime beaucoup nicola
sirkis mais c'est vrai qu'un don chine
c'est pas la rigolade c'est pas tout et
pourtant maxime gainey est ton nicola
sirkis je comprends pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais le maire
ce pas
[Applaudissements]
zéro mais tu as trouvé dans ce talus en
france en 2000 voilà celle qui
s'identifient
à dix on est charmé
[Applaudissements]
encore
le times
[Applaudissements]
un baleineau plus là et là sans éclat le
vol le remplacer franchement il ya
n'importe quoi nicolaï michel même mais
tu as fait le concept donc mais s'était
inventée là tout de suite j'ai été
inspiré par l'esprit nadar cas c'est se
croisent à un mix entre nicolas sirkis
et grand corps malade un peu plus bas à
marcher que sa canne un peu comme ça non
c'est bon est-ce qu'il va tout j'adore
d'un corps malade sa saga
merci allez faire un tour à les voir si
vous n'avez pas pour 10 ou pendant la
honda qui après oui ah ouais on à claude
françois
isabelle morini bosc qui va rejoindre il
sera juste un côtier et regarde derrière
il ya toute sa famille merci d'être là
merci merci à la famille dit hannon vous
oui merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce à peu près la seule occasion où j'ai
de me refaire tous on regarde après ça
va chier
oui franchement alors ça c'est trois
fois celle annoncée merci reste correct
françois s'il est il a franchement t'es
chiant mais je te vion après tu vas
hyper bien c'est très beau mais
franchement wateridge impossible cette
fois ça t'a plu et j'ai adoré
habana o si ça continue je me disais
mais la carte et du commerce a connu
nous reste encore à présent un duo miss
france
et je ne vous dira pourquoi roquois
cedar cas mais ils ont choisi ça à ce
que chacun a choisi sa tenue vous
sachiez chacun s'est dit je vais être
d'arcade dans cette tenue dans ce
personnage donc c'est à vous de voir de
refroidir et fo d'arc à pitre #fb
d'arcade où les gipsy kings je sais pas
quel moment vous êtes d'accord
la civière de n'être pas du tout
d'accord
vous êtes anti d'arcade et donc regarder
et à miss france avec raymond et bernard
montiel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour
à donner je voudrais écouter je vais les
écouter quand même limitation de raymond
de dos des caisses qui dit je te
rappelle la part de la petite dernière
n'a pas de problème avec m
mais calme-toi mais pas faire perdre je
suis pour la paix dans les marais la
dernière étoile à mes toiles et nous
travaillons vraiment c'est pas mal mais
moi il est un gréement et hop américain
est incroyable journée moi je connais je
peux avoir assez des travaux et on
termine ces gens très avec gilles verdez
continue dans la tristesse
[Applaudissements]
la tempe à la barre car les mecs qu'il a
des très belles choses sans rigoler
c'est il a des traits belge en ces
matières est franchement très ma soeur
elle a des belges où sont les élus ne
l'a pas mal choisi mais sachez que j'ai
tué
non quand même pas à ce nom bref pas mal
de débats franchement ils essaient de la
gambas et de la vente à l'aise il est
beau c'est que gilles verdez je me
demande si t'es pas d'homme d'été tôt
sévriens avec le beau gosse on est
excellent sur la plage il peut être pas
mal de mes relais toujours dit qu'il
était beau nu ouais ouais ouais bah je
commence à y croire de plus en plus mais
je te le jure que reviendra le 21 juin
dar k o qui a été un peu dark ah bon
vous voulez je vous dise moi qui ai des
bouillet mois alors c'est la danse de
maxime bernier était au top du top
il nous a fait une danse tu veux nous tu
ne la refera pas la fera près d'accord
merci ou alors d'axa im hüss la tête on
l'offre après c'est beaucoup et tout le
monde nous la réclame
[Rires]